good morning Hank it's Tuesday August
26th and spoiler alert we're finally
going to talk about the second half of
Catcher in the Rye although I don't know
exactly what about the book could be
spoiled Hank I mean like spoiler life is
hard and sad Hank when I first decided I
was going to make two videos about the
Catcher in the Rye I was thinking that
the second video would be all about the
tension between innocence and experience
and how that red hunting cap which is
the same color as his dead brother Ali's
hair is this kind of security blanket
for Holden that he holds on to and I was
going to talk about the ducks in the
pond in Central Park and how nothing
ever changes at the Natural History
Museum which is what Holden likes about
it so much and that heartbreakingly sad
moment at the end with the carousel and
the Hat and Phoebe and everything but
actually now that I've reread the book I
don't want to talk about any of that
I want to talk about what I think is the
real purpose of symbolism and metaphor
and all of the tricks that authors use
to try to make you believe in stories in
a deeper way there's this sociologist I
like named Peter Berger and he wrote in
one of his books the difference between
dogs and people is that dogs know how to
be dogs and it seems to me that one of
the ways that we don't come into this
world knowing how to be a person is that
we don't really know what to do about
empathy like the weird thing about
self-consciousness is that you become
aware of the fact that you can never
fully feel someone else's pain and that
someone else can never fully feel your
pain I mean the same goes for joy but
since we're talking about Holden
Caulfield we got to focus narrowly in on
the pain now Hank the fact that empathy
is a limited human talent is a good
thing because our brains are too small
and too primitive to function if we're
feeling everyone's pain and everyone's
joy and everyone's excitement everyone's
loneliness and everyone's boredom all at
the same time the question is how do we
get to a place where we can empathize
with each other enough to take care of
each other enough to get through this
veil of Tears and this is where the fact
that there are two Holden's in this
story comes into play there's the Holden
who the story is happening to and then
there's a Holden who's telling us about
it the hold knew the story is happening
to is almost a total failure at getting
people to listen to him like basically
in the second half of the book what does
he do it's the same thing he did in the
first half he walks around meet some
people and tries to get them to listen
to him and they refuse and then toward
the end you think that there's this
adult who's actually
finally gonna listen to him and then
Holden wakes up and the guys like
patting his head and it's totally creepy
and hugely sad and if that's your only
Holden I have to say that I don't see a
lot of hope in this novel what I see in
the Holden who the book is happening to
is a kid who's alone and afraid and
scared and who no one hears who no one
ever bothers to listen to
now you can blame this on the people
that Holden reaches out to or you can
blame it on Holden himself but the fact
of the matter is it's no one's fault
because it's not our fault that empathy
is inherently limited everyone in the
book including Holden is self-involved
but they're self-involved because that
is the nature of being a person so if
you only think about the Holden the
stories happening - it's pretty crap
depressing crap is the new darn
apparently it's when I think about the
other Holden that I get hopeful Hank
because a year later he's writing a
story about the person he was and the
way he writes the story makes us care
now we are able to listen to him now we
are able to empathize that's the miracle
of text I would argue but it's also the
miracle of non-literal communication the
hunting hat the movies the carousel
that's his way into us that's how he
gets inside of us and makes us care
makes us believe in him makes us realize
that he is a person in the same way that
we are so ultimately Hank that's my
answer to people who say that all that
English class stuff ruins books all that
English stuff is Holden's way into us
and our way out of ourselves Hank I'll
see you soon
okay Willie tell the nerdfighters their
next clue tell them that the next clue
is taped to a sign and Daniel business
front yard